Ahoy matey!
Thank you for inviting me over today, Maria.
We make a good pirate team.
I'm glad you could come.
I think I hit buried treasure.
That's not treasure, that's trash.
Actually, Peter, it sort of is treasure.
What do you mean?
Come on, I'll show you.
It's a plastic bottle which means we can recycle it in this bin.
But isn't that the trash?
No, it's the recycling.
See? That symbol means recycling not trash.
You want to make sure when you put recycling away, you're putting it in the right bin.
It might look like trash but has a very different use.
Wow! it's almost like magic.
It is magic.
I'm gonna make sure I always recycle.
I'll tell my mom we should get a recycling bin at our house too.
You can also help out by using reusable water bottles.
And filling them up again at home...
...instead of buying water bottles you only use once and then throw away.
Wow, helping the Earth is easy.
It is! Now come on, let's keep digging!
Maybe we'll find more treasure.